الى اوكرانيا حيث اعلن الجيش الاوكراني
حاله تاهب الجوي في عموم البلاد تحسبا
لهجمات روسيه ياتي ذلك في اعقاب شان الجيش
الروسي في ساعات الفجر هجوما واسعا
بالطائرات المسيره استهدف العاصمه ومقاطعه
جنوبيه عده ولا سيما اوديسا
وميكولايفرسون
الجنوبيه البلاد وقال الجانب الاوكراني ان
دفاعاته اسقطت خلال هذا الهجوم خمس
وثلاثين طائره مسيره وعلى الجهتين
الجنوبيه والشرقيه اكدت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه تنفيذ القوات الروسيه 16 هجوما
صاروخيا واحدى وسطينا غاره جويه اضافه الى
50 هجوما بمنظومات صاروخيه اخرى وفي
اوديسا جنوبا قلى حاكم المدينه ان الجيش
الروسي هاجم مناطق ماهوله بقاذفات هجوميه
من طراز تبوليد 22 انطلاقا من اجواء شبه
جزيره القرم مشيرا الى اسقاط دفاعات
الاوكرانيه بعد الصواريخ ومن الجانب
الروسي على وزاره الدفاع عن قصف قاذفه
الروسيه بقنابل موجهه نقطه انتشار لمن
وصفتهم بمرتزقه اجانب في مقاطعه خركيف